Sekarang yang kita dah kupas semua elemen VQE, jom kita
rumuskan apa yang kita pelajari dan tengok macam mana komputer kuantum melaksanakannya.
Kita mulakan dengan reference state yang dipilih dengan bijak, circuit berparameter,
pilihan parameter awal dan satu Hamiltonian.
Kita hantar semua ini ke komputer kuantum kita.
Sebelum Hamiltonian boleh dilaksanakan pada ansatz state,
kita perlu buat pre-pemprosesan klasik terhadap circuit tu
supaya ia boleh dibaca oleh perkakasan kuantum dalam proses yang dipanggil transpilation.
Penting juga untuk memanfaatkan sepenuhnya
seni bina qubit dalam perkakasan sebenar bagi dapat hasil yang terbaik.
Proses-proses ini selalu diurus secara automatik supaya kita tak perlu
tahu secara eksplisit tentang konektiviti qubit,
kesetiaan gate dan sebagainya.
Sekarang tugasnya adalah untuk ukur keadaan yang terhasil
dan anggarkan nilai jangkaan, yang akan dioptimumkan lagi
oleh pengoptimum klasik.
Pengukuran ini dilakukan dengan memutar asas pengukuran
dan kemudian menggabungkan keputusan pengukuran untuk dapatkan nilai jangkaan.
Keputusan berparameter ini kemudiannya disuap
ke dalam pengoptimum klasik, yang mencari parameter baru untuk keadaan tersebut.
Kemudian proses ini diulang.
Pre-pemprosesan klasik mencipta circuit berparameter yang baru
dan kita gunakan Hamiltonian yang sama seperti sebelumnya.
Perlu diingat bahawa dalam keseluruhan proses VQE, kita hanya ubah keadaan
melalui parameter yang semakin lama semakin menghampiri ground state.
Kita ulangi ini sehingga kita berpuas hati dengan hasilnya.
Dan itulah dia.
Nama saya Victoria Lipinska dan ini adalah kursus variational quantum eigensolver.